is Boris Johnson actually up to
well Boris is is being Boris but I
wouldn't say this is this is a
completely unhealthy help uh
intervention
as I say the Prime Minister I think will
acknowledge that uh having the Northern
Ireland protocol Bill there having the
the work uh that the former prime
minister did is has helped us get where
we are but it's always been our
preference to try and have a negotiated
settlement and and that is what everyone
is working to there's still a lot to be
done but progress has been made I would
hope if we arrive at a good deal that
everyone would be supporting it but I I
come back to the point Trevor and I I'm
sorry to repeat it but it is a pretty
fundamental one it doesn't really matter
what any of us in the House of Commons
think about this the deal has to satisfy
the people of Northern Ireland